[Musica]
[Applauso]
tutti noi abbiamo un sogno
un'aspirazione il mio sogno personale
dari biologa e ricercatrice è quello che
si possa in un prossimo prossimo futuro
un vicino futuro riuscire a fare ricerca
biomedica senza sofferenza forse lo
sapete
ogni anno milioni di animali vengono
sacrificati per fare ricerca li
utilizziamo ad esempio per testare gli
effetti di sostanze potenzialmente
tossiche per la salute umana ma anche
per studiare le malattie umane
tuttavia quello che sta emergendo negli
ultimi anni e che la sperimentazione
animale è intrinsecamente incerta
pensate che la capacità predittiva dei
test sugli animali ovvero la capacità di
predire possibili effetti tossici per la
salute umana testando una sostanza sugli
animali è piuttosto bassa
non è molto dissimile dal lancio di una
monetina questa bassa capacità
predittiva potete ben immaginare non
agevola la salvaguardia della salute
umana
troppo spesso e molto spesso scopriamo
gli effetti tossici di alcune sostanze o
di alcuni farmaci direttamente
sull'essere umano sugli uomini le donne
quando invece prima questa stessa
sostanza questo stesso farmaco non
avevano generato particolari effetti
sospetti nell'animale chiediamoci poi
un'altra cosa
i quali animali stiamo parlando per lo
più priamo di questi di roditori topi e
ratti
l'ottanta per cento circa degli animali
usati per fare ricerca doppie rate nei
confronti dei quali non proviamo grande
simpatia diciamocelo francamente ci
disgusta una volta eppure questi
animaletti provano sentimenti ed empatia
come è stato dimostrato da numerose
ricerche oltre che di roditori parliamo
anche di conigli i cani i gatti
gli anfibi gli uccelli di pesci parliamo
perfino di primati non umani tipo
scimmie scimpanzé per quanto riguarda la
ricerca biomedica nello specifico
nuovamente il topo e la specie più usata
e parlando di ricerca biomedica facciamo
un esempio su tutti alzheimer per quanto
riguarda l'alzheimer per l'appunto i
topi geneticamente modificati sono di
fatto la specie che va per la maggiore
si ritengono utili questi topi poiché
attraverso di essi è possibile studiare
alcuni dei tratti patologici
dell'alzheimer come ad esempio
l'accumulo di proteine amiloidi
tuttavia quello che ormai si sa è che
questi animali non sviluppano realmente
l'alzheimer ma solamente alcuni tratti
patologici di questa complessa sindrome
pensate inoltre che attraverso questi
topi in realtà si può studiare
relativamente l'alzheimer sviluppano la
matta la patologia in giorni o settimane
quando invece nell'essere umano
l'alzheimer richiede decenni per
consolidarsi e questo aspetto del tempo
ci porta ad un altro importante
riflessione tempo o kronos dal greco le
patologie croniche e degenerative
richiedono tempo a manifestarsi in
questo tempo lo potete ben immaginare da
voi stessi
lo stile di vita gioca un ruolo
fondamentale nutrizione attività fisica
allenamento cognitivo perfino la qualità
del nostro sonno il microbioma
intestinale tutto gioca un ruolo
fondamentale nella determinazione del
rischio di queste patologie e come
potete nuovamente intuire l'utilizzo di
modelli animali in questo senso non
aiuta molto
è pressoché impossibile riprodurre in
una specie diversa dall'essere umano
tutti questi fattori così
intrinsecamente collegati allo stile di
vita umano
vedete bene la nostra anatomia la nostra
fisiologia il nostro sistema immunitario
il modo in cui interagiamo e reagiamo
gli stimoli esterni differiscono
sostanzialmente fra le specie animali
un esempio su tutti è lo scimpanzé
pensate lo scimpanzè la specie a noi più
vicini
tra uomo scimpanzé all dal punto di
vista genetico c'è solo un 2 per cento
di differenza ma è nel passaggio da geni
e proteine che si riscontra ben
l'ottanta per cento di diversità queste
diversità tra le specie così come anche
i possibili effetti avversi
imprevedibili che la sperimentazione
scientifica può avere sulle cavie sono
alcuni dei fattori alla base della crisi
di riproducibilità in ambito scientifico
questa crisi di riproducibilità si
riscontra anche dal punto di vista dei
test sui farmaci
i test sui farmaci prima di arrivare
all'uomo prevedono al test sugli animali
i test pre clinici tuttavia qui si
riscontrano dei problemi assistiamo ad
un 90 per cento di media di fallimento
di ciò che viene testato negli animali
perché nel 90 per cento dei casi
semplicemente non funziona per gli
esseri umani
anche qui facciamo un esempio
l'alzheimer
uno studio del 2014 ha preso in
considerazione 244 farmaci pensate
testate in ben quattro 113 trial clinici
nel decennio che va dal 2002 al 2012
solamente un farmaco su 244 ha passato
tutte le fasi dalla fase preclinica fase
1 fase ii fase iii questo si traduce in
un tasso del fallimento equivalente a
quello che vedete scritto qui 99,6 per
cento è un tasso di fallimento
inaccettabile
attualmente per l'alzheimer abbiamo di
fatto quattro farmaci e questi quattro
farmaci sono pressoché inutili nella
prognosi a lungo termine funzionano
solamente in una minima parte di
pazienti e conferiscono benefici minimi
sono nulli è possibile che una dei
fattori alla base di questo fallimento
in ambito pre clinico sia legato alla
sovrastima e al suo utilizzo dei modelli
animali per lo studio delle patologie
umane e bene che a fare dunque
beh le patologie umane si possono
innanzitutto studiare sugli esseri umani
esistono numerosissimi studi clinici
osservazione
finale interventistici che hanno
dimostrato essere estremamente utili per
cogliere informazioni utili all'uomo è
realmente efficaci ma anche nel
disegnare nuovi farmaci campioni di
sangue biologico campioni di liquido
cerebro spinale collezionamento di
biopsie post mortem uniti a tecniche di
neuroimaging così come anche a culture
cellulari derivate da pazienti
rappresentano delle fonti insostituibili
ed incredibilmente utili per studiare le
malattie
qui al centro comune di ricerca dove ci
occupiamo anche della convalida
validazione promozione di metodi
alternativi alla sperimentazione animale
usiamo queste cellule cellule umane
differenziati in neuroni queste culture
neuronali vengono utilizzate per testare
gli effetti di sostanze potenzialmente
tossiche neurotossiche appunto ma
modelli molto simili a questo anche più
complessi di questo cresciuti in 3d in
3d tridimensionalità possono già oggi
essere utilizzate per studiare le
patologie umane anche ad esempio per
formulare nuovi farmaci
questo sta già succedendo nell'ambito
dell'alzheimer modelli simili a questo
possono essere integrati ad approcci in
silico computazionali per definire i
meccanismi molecolari che sono alla base
delle patologie al fine anche di trovare
nuove possibili strategie di cura sia
farmacologica che non c'è un però la
strada che porterà all ampia
accettazione alla convalida di questi
metodi e ancora un po lunga pensate che
l'unione europea già dal 2013 ha messo
al bando la sperimentazione animale per
testare i cosmetici
se però nel settore della cosmesi della
cosmetica ma soprattutto della
tossicologia in senso più lato la
sperimentazione animale e i suoi limiti
è già discusso da parecchio tempo i
nuovi metodi stanno avanzando e nel
settore della della medicina e della
sperimentazione biomedica che si
riscontrano delle restrizioni delle
difficoltà l'utilizzo di animali a
sperimentazione
male semplicemente considerato
obbligatoria perché a norma di legge
inoltre regolamentata anche dai codici
etici definiti nella dichiarazione di
helsinki e nel codice di norimberga
dalla seconda guerra mondiale in poi per
cui di fatto di strada ce n'è da fare
però c'è anche da chiedersi alla luce
degli evidenti fallimenti in ambito
traslazionale dal modello animale
all'umano e anche alla luce della
disponibilità di nuovi metodi
attualmente disponibili di nuove
tecnologie
perfino di tecnologie di medicina
personalizzata che permetterebbero di
fatto di creare dei nuovi trattamenti su
misura per ogni singolo paziente
forse oggi i tempi sono maturi per
ragionare speculare sulla possibilità di
un cambiamento di paradigma anche
nell'ambito della ricerca biomedica e
ovviamente questo cambiamento di
paradigma passa per che cosa passa per
nuovi approcci normativi certamente ma
passa anche per un'ampia discussione che
deve essere fatta con la comunità
scientifica in generale e con gli enti
finanziatori della ricerca
sull'importanza reale di investire
risorse ed energie
i metodi che siano più rilevanti per
l'essere umano eticamente accettabili ed
ecologicamente sostenibili
qui stiamo parlando anche di un
approccio diverso alla ricerca da un
approccio mentale più riduzionistico
dove si prende il singolo pezzo di un
puzzle e si cerca di studiarlo
riprodurlo in una specie animale
piuttosto che in una cultura di cellule
ad un approccio molto più olistico
complesso e multidimensionale in cui gli
esseri viventi vengono ri concepiti non
più come tanti pezzetti di un solo
puzzle ma come esseri complessi in
relazione all'ambiente che li circonda
al fine di cogliere interezza e
integrazione delle loro parti
inoltre stiamo anche parlando di
coraggio affinché questo paradigma cambi
coraggio e determinazione il coraggio ad
esempio di uscire dalla propria zona di
comfort il coraggio di ammettere che
alcune teorie devono essere
riconsiderate lì dove risulti in
obsolete
e ovviamente io vi lascio con questo mio
sogno personale che torna un po quello
che dicevo all'inizio io penso che già
da oggi sia possibile fare ricerca
biomedica senza sofferenza gli strumenti
ci sono e la conoscenza c'è e pensiamo
che un altra cosa la sofferenza di cui
vi sto parlando non è solamente la
sofferenza degli animali usati per fare
ricerca e anche la sofferenza di quei
milioni di pazienti che ogni giorno
aspettano delle cure realmente efficaci
che tardano ad arrivare e che potrebbero
addirittura non arrivare mai
se si consegue se si continua a
perseguire ea perseguire nell'utilizzo
di approcci fuorvianti
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]